al'approche du passage du tour de france
à chatou la ville a mis le vélo à
l'honneur le temps d'un week end les 3
et 4 juillet l'île des impressionnistes
accueillait la fête du tour le but
promouvoir le département et le vélo
sous toutes ses formes c'est de rappeler
les yvelines est vraiment une terre de
vélo fin on accueille des événements
beaucoup d'événements sportifs nationaux
fois on développe beaucoup de vélo route
aussi sur le sur le territoire donc on a
cet aspect loisirs tourisme sportif
événementielle sur place plusieurs
activités freestyle airbag vélo smoothie
parcours pour les enfants ou encore cet
atelier sur les drôles de vélos au
tandem inverser un tout petit vélo micro
bike aux plus grands le granby par
exemple s'est effectivement montré qu'il
ya plein de façons différentes de faire
du vélo qu'on a des réflexes à vélo
qu'on oublie qu'on a et quand on utilise
un vélo un peu différent il faut changer
sa façon de faire on est arrivés ya pas
très longtemps mais on a déjà fait deux
trois activités pour l'instant les
enfants sont super contents donc les
parents sont contents pour les enfants
pour les grands même pour découvrir des
vélos un petit peu extraordinaire on a
vu là bas sur l'activité avec des tout
petits vélos et des grands vélo on vient
d'arriver on a découvert cet atelier les
plans de long un peu bizarre affaire on
en laisse avec les enfants j'en ai fait
un peu tout seul ça c est super sympa le
départ de la dernière étape du tour de
france partira de chatou le dimanche 18
juillet